hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well towards the end
of chapter one of his work language
truth and logic a Jair is going to
discuss a general way in his view how
metaphysical propositions or assertions
or claims wind up getting made and
remember that for air generally
metaphysical is going to be not a good
thing I actually technically can't say
it's good or bad because in his view
metaphysical assertions are actually
meaningless or nonsense they fail the
criterion of verifiability and they're
not actually tautologies either things
that are logically necessary because of
the structure of our language so they're
going to be problematic and it part of
his goal is to try to show that that
these really don't say anything or
assert anything and you know after doing
that he says that what we want to do is
to show how metaphysical assertions or
propositions or statements come to be
made what is going on when we're doing
this and the general idea is that we're
seduced by some of the strange quirks of
our language so that we take as he says
we postulate real nonexistent entities
which are resulting from the
superstition that there must be real
entities corresponding to grammatical
subjects so because we name something
and talk about it in language we assume
there must be something corresponding to
it and we are thereby being misled or
seduced by some of the features of our
very own language
another way of Plenty framing us this is
a linguistic problem rather than an
actual metaphysical problem so one of
the prime examples that he uses is
referencing Martin Heidegger 'he's
famous statement that the nothing
nothing's you know das nicht nicked it
which has been attacked by the logical
positivists as not just meaningless but
a great example of Heidegger's jobs you
know obfuscation
of language and his messiness and and
perhaps even being totally misled
himself in thinking that in talking
about nothing we're actually talking
about anything I mean to be fair
Heidegger does very carefully say
nothing isn't something but you could
still make the the criticism that what's
going on here is mistaking the fact that
we have a name or a word for something
even if it's a really weird one like a
privat of nothing and thinking that it
must correspond to if not something at
least you know something out there in a
different sense that we could attribute
things to or say something about and in
to be fair and Heidegger's work that
nothing does some work right
particularly in what is metaphysics so
that that's an interesting example that
air is bringing up another that I think
is a little bit easier to relate to if
we think about the history of philosophy
is this question about the reality of
universals you know what is booked miss
you know this is a book what is the
essence of being a book is it a property
that all books have in common or is it
perhaps a platonic form or is it an idea
in the mind of God or is it some sort of
thing in this book itself there's a lot
of different versions of the problem of
universals and air is saying listen
there really shouldn't be any problem of
universals because universals don't have
reality as entities we just think that
they do because we're seduced once again
by our grammar the fact that we can talk
about universals we can say books do
certain things you know books are
wonderful right Reading Is Fundamental
what is this reading that you're talking
about is it all of the acts of reading
combined is it some sort of substantive
so those are the sorts of things that
that air has in mind and he says that
the general problem is that we assume
that because we can predicate something
of a subject that that subject is
therefore an entity and it exists in
some way so a prime example of this he
talks about it at great length is
substance and he mentions he talked
about this a little bit earlier he says
that it happens to be the case that we
cannot in our language he means English
of course but we could think of pretty
much all the indo-european languages
right
we cannot refer to the sensible
properties of a thing without
introducing a word or phrase which
appears to stand for the thing itself as
opposed to anything which may be said
about it let's take it as an example
book right so this book is black and
white and pinkish in in color it is a
short book it is in fact an old book as
you could tell if you're looking at it
it is written in English these are all
properties of book but we could say well
there's a book and then it has those
properties first you have a book a
subject and then you have all of these
things
like Aristotle would call accidents
right or qualities or you know pick
whatever other thing you know you want
to say about it and the book can be we
can say the book is in space over here
or the book is now smacking me in the
head all these different things we can
we can predicated on it the book smells
like old books hey all those sorts of
things so says that that we've got this
idea of the thing that underlies the
sensible properties why do we assume
that because our language leads us into
thinking that but our language is
seducing us leading us astray he says we
use the term substance to refer to the
thing itself we can do that in a generic
sense and talk about substance so like
you know the substance of this or the
substance of this chalkboard the
substance of my tie the substance of my
own flesh and we can talk about each of
those individual substances as well what
they are says we use the term substance
to refer to the thing itself from the
fact that we happen to employ a single
word to refer to a thing and make that
word the grammatical subject of the
sentences in which we refer to the
sensible appearances of the thing says
there's two mistakes that we make here
one is thinking that it follows that the
thing itself is a single and simple
entity this book you know could be
understood as an assemblage of pages for
example and there's no more reason for
us to focus on the book Ness the unity
of this then there is on the parts of it
I suppose or the different qualities the
other thing he says is that there's no
reason to think that a thing cannot be
defined in terms of the totality of its
appearances so there's no thing behind
the appearances of this book this thing
just is all those appearances the
whiteness blackness pinkness the smell
of the old book the all the you know
multiple things with all these letters
and
underlining the qualities that it has of
length and depth and breadth and all of
those things the sound that it makes
when I smack it on the stool all of
these things are the book there is
nothing beyond it so you might think
about you know dick Hurtz famous you
know piece of wax example where he looks
at the thing in terms of its qualities
and then he brings the wax close to the
fire uses all of its qualities are
changing what what underlies it well
it's the substance itself of the wax
which is an extended thing air is saying
we don't have to assume that our
language leads us to think about that
but we don't have to buy into that
another example a little bit more
abstract the metaphysical concept of
being he says that our language has
unfortunately in his view the same
grammatical form used for existential
and attributed propositions now what are
existential and attributed propositions
saying that the book is old is
attributive you're saying this this
object here has the property of a Jinnah
so it is a certain you know time period
of age or it's from a certain period or
whatever however we're going to construe
being old right we don't have to have a
perfect understanding in order to make
this work to say the book is or the book
exists
that's an existential statement did you
see the difference between the two for
one you're asserting that something has
existence that it is in being for the
other you're saying how it is what what
sort of attributes what sort of
properties what sort of observations we
can make of it now you can observe that
something exists and you can also
observe that something exists in a
certain way that it has properties right
so he says here that simpler and clearer
instance in the way in which a
consideration of grammar leads to
metaphysics is the case of the
metaphysical concept of being the origin
of our temptation to raise questions
about capital
b-being about which no conceivable
experience would enable to answer lies
in the fact that in our language
sentences which expressing existential
propositions and sentences which express
attributive propositions may be of the
same grammatical form so he uses an
example here that leads us a little bit
of astray but we'll come back to the
being itself in a sec the sentences
martyrs exist and martyrs suffer
illustrates this different saying
martyrs exist existential statement
saying martyrs suffer
attributive statement they're both
grammatically quite similar they're a
noun followed by an intransitive verb
the fact that they have grammatically
the same appearance leads one he says to
assume that they are of the same logical
type now what about being as such can we
actually talk about being as such it
depends on what you mean by talk yes we
can we could say being exists we can
string those terms together because we
have the verb you know to be turned into
a gerund right being or we could we
could do it with other things as well we
could say to be exists or we could come
up with all sorts of other things the
beingness of beings or whatever we want
grammatically we can do that in terms of
whether we're saying something
meaningful ere would say it's a whole
different issue saying being exists is
not the same thing as asserting that the
book exists the book is an actual thing
right it could exist or I couldn't
destroy it now no longer exists you have
to ask yourself what what is actually
meant by being how would you empirically
verify this sort of thing and the answer
is from the perspective air is working
out you can't so really you're just
saying nonsense in talking about being
existing or being loving us or any other
thing that you might say about being the
last one that he talks about is
fictional things and he uses an example
of you
so when we say things like dogs are
faithful and unicorns are fictitious
we're again being misled by grammar were
thinking that he says there's an
assumption that these are the same
logical type so when we say that things
are fictitious
like unicorns we are asserting that they
have this property of being fictitious
and you could say well wait a second how
the hell can you assert a property of
something if it doesn't exist you can't
say the book is black if the book isn't
black well you can I mean the books in
Sherlock Holmes study are presumably
bound in leather and have all sorts of
different rich colors or something like
that Sherlock Holmes is taller than
Watson Sherlock Holmes doesn't exist and
his apartment at whatever Baker Street
never presumably existed I know there
might have been some model that it was
drawn from by Arthur Conan Doyle but
he's a fictional character is he not so
how is it how does it work for fictional
things ear says that our grammar
misleads us into this assumption that
fictitious things are real in some non
empirical mode and heir says well there
isn't any non empirical mode of being
real that's what it means to be real
we're being once again misled by the way
our language works so these are all
examples in ayres view of how
metaphysics gets generated out of not
paying close enough attention to how our
language works and important
distinctions that we might want to draw
about our language
you